hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle my name is mark ellis i'm your
host and i'm thrilled to be here
particularly on today because it's a
show that i came to a little later i
wasn't watching this week to week like
our two guests i believe were ever since
it debuted seasons and seasons and maybe
a decade ago dexter is the show we're
talking about we're excited about dexter
right now in 2021 going into 2022
because we have dexter new blood that
has just premiered its first episode so
we're excited to follow that and we'll
talk about that a little bit later in
the show along with some other things
that maybe our competitors didn't love
about dexter but we're here for binge
battle and here is how it's going to
work we have competitors they're going
to have their opening argument for
whatever topic i present with them
they're each going to get a rebuttal and
then a final argument now if you're a
fan of the show or you're joining us for
the very first time
fair warning spoilers are in play here
so if you have not yet seen dexter if
you want to get into dexter maybe you'd
come back to visit us a little bit later
after you've done so or maybe this is
the show that you might hear some
spoilers but it gets you into wanting to
see dexter i had some of it ruined for
me but i watched it and i binged it and
i loved it and so i'm excited to talk
with our two very special guests today
here on binge battle and joining me
today for this epic binge battle is none
other than the author of the way we all
became the brady bunch and she is also a
noted tv critic you can follow her on
twitter and instagram at tv screener
it's kim potts hello kim welcome to the
show hey thank you guys i'm excited to
be here and talk dexter i am so happy to
have you when did dexter first come on
your radar because i had people telling
me since it really debuted that it's a
show i need to watch and i just never
really got around to doing it until much
later in the game how about you were you
initially on the dexter train or did you
have to play some catch up i was
initially on the dexter train i mean how
can you not watch us if you love you
know it was definitely among the the
prestige drama of the time and and how
can you not if you've watched the
sopranos and all of those other great um
dramas how can you not watch a drama
about a serial killer who kills serial
killers
it's certainly everything that we love
in modern tv right because it's great
drama and it's also it's got that true
crime serial killer element that
i know i know everybody enjoys watching
these days and i know that that is
always at the top of the list for
our other special guests today who you
know from the upcoming film pretty boy
which you can catch next year she also
has a disney plus project coming out
you've already seen her on shows like
criminal minds and ncis it is grace
hancock hello grace welcome to the show
and the particular binge battle that
you're working with today it seems like
this show is custom made for you and all
of your
the things that you enjoy
watching of course yes thank you so much
for having me i'm so excited i do love
this show i love murder you know i just
like dark stuff um i'm very very happy
to be here to discuss murder so thank
you for having me when did you first
stumble upon this show that does feature
murder yeah well yeah i did i was also
watching it in real time i remember it
coming out and i feel like in my circle
at the time which was unfortunately very
conservative it was a very like
controversial show which made me love it
even more and i remember really being
like oh this is really dark and really
great and really loving it i was like
and all the other people who really
loved it were like my people so it was
definitely something that i watched in
real time and also michael c hall is
also a redheaded vegan so i was like
this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me so i love it i still love
it today
oh there you go it's it's everything
that we love all in one program so i do
want to ask you all about dexter new
blood at the end of the show after we
have our fun little binge battle here
and then i also want to get your hot
takes on some things about dexter but
these are all questions for later and
then we also have your streaming pics
you're going to recommend everybody
that's all coming later in the show but
right now it's the binge battle and the
way that it works here is each of you
are going to get a minute once i present
a topic you have a minute to choose
whoever or whatever you like from that
topic the best you're going to debate
you're going to uh argue your point with
fervor but again it's competitive to a
point there is going to be a winner at
the end we're just here to celebrate
dexter we're not here to take the gloves
off and so i'll give you a topic you get
a minute and then once your opponent
does their minute you get a 30 second
rebuttal your opponent gets the same and
then we each have a final statement
it'll be around 10 seconds to keep it
nice and tidy so with all of that we
introduced kim first grace was second so
now grace you have the right to go first
in round number one if you're both ready
to go
100 let's do it let's go
all right then topic number one for our
dexter binge battle is best villain but
it comes with a caveat because we all
just love the trinity killer so much so
the trinity killer is off the board here
in round number one your best villain
not named the trinity killer i mean you
can't have a great show without great
villains so grace hancock you are on the
clock in round number one who is the
best villain in all of dexter
well i mean there's so many great
options but if i have to pick my very
favorite i'm 100 voting for hannah mckay
she's smart she's cunning she's slippery
she has money stashed away she's evaded
prison for a very long time she's a
successful flower entrepreneur she's
very very fearless her literally facing
death her responses do what you got to
do if that's not the most metal thing
i've ever heard in my life i don't know
who you're hanging out with she doesn't
put up with anything she sees what she
wants and she takes it which i can
totally respect but the bottom line with
hannah mckay is that we're absolutely
rooting for her we want them to end up
together she's you know a skinny white
blonde woman which we know dexter loves
and she has the edge that lumen was
totally missing and the bottom line is
that her and dexter are totally cut from
the same cloth this is his best case
scenario he's never going to do better
than hannah mckay in my opinion
i i feel like you have matchmaking in
your future i know if you've looked into
that but i just i it felt nice to have
you it seems like you're looking out for
both of them and you want them to to
remain together yeah weirdly yes you're
totally rooting for two serial killers
which is the beauty of the show
it's probably safe for societies to pair
serial killers with each other uh so now
let's go to kim for your counter one
minute on the clock kim potts who is the
best villain in dexter
uh
it is a hard choice because they were
all pretty great i mean the the show
cast well and it wrote those villains
well um but i'm gonna have to pick
miguel prado who was played by jimmy
smith
and part of the reason i think that he
was such a great villain is because we
don't see jimmy smith as a villain we've
seen him in l.a law and nypd blue and he
even goes on to play the pimp with the
heart of gold and son a and sons of
anarchy so
it helped that that we weren't used to
seeing him as a villain so when he did
you know present himself as this super
villain um who first became dexter's you
know probably the first real true friend
dexter thought he had ever had um
so much so that he had him be the best
man at his wedding to rita um and they
were couple friends with with miguel and
and his uh wife but you know of course
in the end as harry had told him dexter
was never going to be able to have a
true friend who knew him
really knew what he did um and that
turned out to be true and also of course
uh spoiler alert dexter has to kill him
because
he you know has not only um is not truly
his friend but he's been using him
because he wants to become a serial
killer himself um and he was in the
right place and he did definitely learn
some some tips and tricks from dexter
but um
yeah it wasn't meant to be for extra to
have to have miguel as his friend and um
but but jimmy smith made a great villain
and and that was a it provided you know
that chance for us to see that dexter
really did in spite of um
you know not having a lot of friends and
and keeping himself at a distance he
really did appreciate having a friend
what he thought he did and and that was
another side of dexter that we haven't
seen at that point
that's why i love this is topic number
one because it's
it's villains it's friends it's lovers
so grace why would you say that hannah
makes makes a better villain in your
mind than someone like a miguel prado
i think it's more just that
i was never
really rooting for miguel in the way
that i was rooting for harry or for
hannah and for harry but i felt like he
just wasn't likable enough for me to be
as invested i felt like immediately i my
first thought wasn't oh good dexter has
a buddy my first thought was like this
feels shady like i don't trust ladies to
head for anything like i didn't like it
he's very like overbearing like kind of
has like this nervous energy that's very
impulsive he didn't know what he was
going to do and dexter so subtle and
subdued and so calculating it was two
very very different energies and they
became friends way too quickly for me he
was like hey nice to meet you do you
want to be my best man and i was like
what this feels weird and i just didn't
trust him and he just wasn't likable
enough for me i wasn't i was kind of
almost immediately rooting for dexter to
take him out which i was good at
okay okay so it just wasn't that that
likeable quality that we do want in some
of our villains kim so why would you say
miguel
makes it where hannah doesn't
well i i actually cannot argue anything
against hannah i think i also wanted
them to get together i mean he's she's
the person that dexter trusted with his
son in the end
spoiler alert um
so you know i you can't i don't think
that you can i don't think that you can
say anything against hannah also as
bruce also said she was right there on
dexter's level i mean i think that's why
he fell in love with her not just
because he likes you know the that's
definitely his type
um in a lot of ways but also because he
and respected her she was as smart as
clever um as capable of getting away
with what she needed to get away with um
as he was and i'm sorry i'm actually i
feel like i'm arguing braces right now
but i can't argue against her point so
um i would just you know it's i think
it's more a personal preference i love
jimmy smits and i loved him playing this
against type character for him
um and i liked the fact that dr dexter
was finally having a friend but um
yeah i can't argue at all against hannah
great
and and it really is why this is such a
fun conversation too is because it with
both of y'all's picks it's like we're
using someone that we want to dexter to
find some you know some happiness with
whether it's with a best friend or
whether it's with someone that he's
going to get between the sheets with so
the the final statement first goes to
grace hancock to support hannah mckay as
your favorite villain
yeah i mean i think yeah it is it does
you know it is a testament to the show
that we're always rooting for little
dexter to have a little girlfriend or a
friend but i just think at the end of
the day hannah was more earned they were
more like connected on a deeper level it
was over time that they built the
relationship i felt like miguel was just
really rushed and too fast a few furious
and then he was dead and i was like okay
all right and kim why why is miguel your
personal preference for your favorite
villain is it the jimmy smith's factor
is it the sort of twist as to who we
thought we knew we thought we knew you
jimmy spence right
um it's both yeah it's definitely
there's definitely the jimmy smith's
back factor um it's the twist which i
thought was a good one um again relative
to the fact that we thought dexter was
finally having a best friend not just a
friend but a really close i mean he you
know has these pseudo friends at work
and and the people that he pretends to
be this normal guy for and and that they
have these work friendships but this was
someone that he thought was
um a real friend who knew who he was and
accepted it and actually
wanted to join in and and someone he
thought he could trust which obviously
is a big thing for dexter too he really
can't trust pretty much anyone
so um that was a big thing for him i
have to go back to what grace said about
little dexter wouldn't that be a great
little animated series
i mean completely messed up but
it would be fun i would watch hey
we have sidcom execs watching this you
you greenlit young sheldon i don't know
why we can't get young dexter out there
i love it if if nothing else it would
make a great comic strip so young dexter
will put that in the can we want dexter
to have a friend we want dexter to have
somebody that he's intimate with and so
it's a tough call for me because i love
jimmy smith i love seeing jimmy smith
show up in anything i'm like hey that's
jimmy smith when he shows up at star
wars i'm like i don't think i don't
think that's yeah i don't care who if
that's bill or gone i'm like no that's
jimmy smith that's the guy from nypd
blue and then you get to the fact that
like by that season though season three
i believe i realized that okay dexter's
not really gonna be even if this friend
might share a very dark hobby with
dexter it's gonna be tough for them to
have that with with hannah it hit me
differently simply because
i really thought this was going to be
something else and and i was excited
about that and so it was more of a
heartbreak when it didn't go the way i
wanted it to with the hannah mckay
storyline so just by by the skin of her
teeth and that's a that's a weird way to
say this based on the show dexter where
we are analyzing things like skin and
teeth uh i think that grace has the
better villain
for this round anyway so grace gets the
point gracie got a point you can go home
now if you want to thank god i'm finally
gonna win something you guys i'm feeling
good about this
you you you have a point and no one can
ever take that away from you and so now
we do go to round number two which is
our best season the best season of
dexter which is notorious for some great
seasons and in the reminds of a lot of
fans some not so great season so we're
gonna kick off with you this time kim
potts what is your favorite season of
dexter well i think we have to say that
everybody
probably agrees that four was the
the superstar season um
of the show but so maybe this i guess
we're picking maybe our second favorite
season um so i'm gonna pick season five
um because it followed that amazing um
season four and that shocking
ending and and i think what most people
consider
to be one of the best season endings
ever uh especially in the prestige drama
world
um
which was
the can we say should we say now it's
was the difference
go ahead yeah yeah we get your spoiler
warning up top so whatever whatever you
want to say we're all good
um so dexter the shocking
uh death murder of um rita by the
trinity killer and so dexter is
just completely beside himself he's
angry he's raging he's
he doesn't know how to deal with this he
has guilt of course
um he thought that he had
he had been able somehow to make this
you know kind of nice little life for
himself that that he didn't think was
going to be possible and then it was
taken away by
um you know he obviously blames himself
um
and then he kind of finds a way though
in season five to to deal with that by
going after jordan chase he was this
horrible
guy he had this gang of friends who um
they found women to rape and torture and
dexter made friends with one of them
lumen uh played by julia stiles and he
kind of finds in helping her get revenge
on these awful people
that he's sort of getting a little bit
of a revenge kind of redeeming himself
for his guilt over rita's death
and um
you know it
it's it was also a different side i
think that we saw dexter who didn't
necessarily think of himself as capable
of emotions but obviously he had them
over the death of rita and
again his guilt and all of that
and um and then he he finally got to
work that out a little bit uh in helping
lumen get her own revenge against jordan
chase and his pals
so it you know it was a good story
um
and i think it was a tough it was
probably a tough season to write after
that incredible fourth season
you know where do you take him after
that and um i think they did a good job
the writers did a good job yeah it was
almost like where do you go after that
will you turn inward and we get a lot
deeper and more layers to this character
that we have come to know over the
previous four seasons so grace
your
favorite season in the history of dexter
i mean absolutely and similarly like
this is gonna be like the nicest binge
battle ever because miguel is a great
villain so i'm gonna totally agree like
season four is fantastic which is
actually what i was gonna talk about but
the interesting part is that i i have
very strong feelings about season five
but i'm going to talk about season four
first if i had to pick a second favorite
i would probably say season one but
number one hands down again like
everybody can agree there's just no fact
to trim in season four it's just it's
such excellent storytelling there's so
much going on but they're all really
really intentionally connected it's not
like there's no weird like fluff plot
lines like everybody comes back to
trinity we have quinn and christine you
know we have lundy coming back
heartbreaking worst thing ever so sad
and then obviously you know john lithgow
is just incredible at everything and his
mo as a serial killer is super
fascinating like the whole trinity that
we find out is actually like a quadruple
thing is just really
like you know obviously
totally disturbing but like in the best
way possible and you have this cool
dynamic of dexter kind of like admiring
him and almost sort of like studying him
like how is he balancing this family
life along with the serial killer like
that dexter at the time is really like
kind of crushing getting crushed into
the weight over under and they're
they're kind of like cat and mouse game
is very reminiscent of the ice truck
killer because i feel like trinity was
the first time that we had another uh
killer who was kind of like they were on
the same page like miguel was like i'm a
baby serial killer fraternity was like
i'm a veteran dexter's like i'm a
veteran like let's be friends so there's
a very like equal playing field that
made it really interesting
it's just a really high energy season
it's a very well developed season and of
course leading up to that insane finale
that literally every time i watch my jaw
is just like on the ground through the
end credits like it's the next day i'm
still stunned i have to go to my
therapist like and then of course
harrison being found in a pool of blood
like just like his father before him
before him is just like the most
beautiful you know terrifying but like
beautiful storytelling that just comes
really full circle there's just
absolutely there's there's just no fat
to trim it's really it's maybe one of my
favorite seasons of television ever
julie
yes season four it gets the lion's share
of the hype and then i'll reserve my
feelings about season four and five for
after i have to make the very difficult
judgment but again coming to it later
might have impacted me differently than
people who are watching it in real time
so um kim let's let's go back to you for
for season five and and why maybe it
didn't have the shocking reveals
on a par with season four but it did
bring a lot of other things to the table
yeah it really did um again kind of that
recognition by dexter that he
he could feel things you know that he
was
um sad about and guilty about rita's
death and
um that he could find a way to work that
out a little bit i mean doing what he
does best of course but
um but and and the fact that he could
feel something for another woman you
know he definitely had some feelings for
lumen
um
so yeah i i i liked that they continued
that that they didn't have i mean i
think lesser writers probably would have
had dexter just you know go on a serial
killing rampage
of his own without involving you know
someone else and that he was helping
this woman and all of these women that
had been victims of um jordan chase and
his friends
i like that they that they you know
gave us a little bit more of the inner
dexter and and didn't just have him you
know go off and be by himself again
we got a lot of emotional depth to
dexter in season five with grace like
you said season four we just had so many
fireworks
right yeah i think also like again like
season four is such a tough act to
follow i almost would have liked though
because and i might even touch on this
later with something else but i feel
like at the end of the day with that
relationship that they spent so much
time building and it was so subtle and
it was so emotional it was kind of like
you know on a on a longer wavelength
than season four um but it ended up kind
of like not having any payoff which
really upset me like deeply deeply
inside but also it's interesting because
i actually would have preferred to see
you know what is this how does a serial
killer become unchained more so than
being a serial killer like i didn't want
him to go introspective i wanted him to
like talk being a serial killer on his
best day it's like you're having this
horrible tragedy i wanted to see him go
nuts like i wanted him to go like full
deb and just like go down like deep down
i don't know what that says about me but
that's just what i wanted to see because
he's such a phenomenal performer i would
have loved to have seen how he tops
being a serial killer on a good day
all right so now final statement time
supporting two very tough seasons to
pick between season five kim potts your
final statement
um i will just say i i think that it was
a pretty amazing job that the writers
did um following season four which i
agree is
is definitely um
one of the best seasons of dexter and
as grace said
one of the best seasons of tv drama ever
so i think that was a particularly tough
act to follow and i i think they made
good choices and and gave us some good
stuff
all right and grace supporting season
four
yeah again like it's it's definitely
a super tough act to follow i just think
at the end of the day maybe the contrast
was a little bit too stark to go from so
high to so like kind of mellowed out and
like a little bit not flat but because
of the contrast it just fell too flat
for me in comparison
and this is why it's such a tough call
for me because i have sympathy for
everybody who watches tv like we all did
in the old days who just had you he saw
an episode and then you had to wait
another week to say what the hell was
gonna happen as somebody who had the
luxury of sitting in their ivory tower
and just binging dexter whenever i felt
like it i could watch an hour i could
watch 15 minutes i could watch nine
hours in a row it didn't matter to me i
saw these seasons a little bit
differently and so i did have season
four hyped up for me a lot and as much
as i enjoyed a lot of that and all the
twists and the reveals and everything it
just seemed like every episode we just
got this huge major moment
season five impressed me so much with
what they were able to do with getting
into the character of dexter because as
as we meet him in season one it's like
this guy's cold and feels no emotion the
most emotion that we got out of dexter
for the most part was in flashbacks when
he's thinking about how his old man was
trying to sort of coach this thing
inside his kit in the right way and we
saw a lot of that come out in season
five and then the addition of lumen and
what that plotline entailed i think it's
an upset pick but i think it's gonna be
my pick today and so
season five gets the on another day
probably could have been season four but
season five gets the call from me and so
kim potts ties grace hancock at the top
you each have a point so you're both
winners today congratulations
and now we just need to sort out who is
the winner that's gonna win today's show
so we move on to
our third round here and this is gonna
be a fun one because it is the favorite
character with the qualifier that you
can't pick our boy dexter morgan so you
can't pick dexter you can't pick any
little dexter's that might appear on
animaniac sometime in the future it has
to just be a character from dexter that
is not named dexter morgan grace hancock
we kick off with you with a minute on
the clock
i mean obviously obviously obviously i'm
picking deb
absolutely a woman after my own heart
she's totally the heartbeat of the show
i think in a lot of ways she's the
heartbeat of dexter the humanity that
she brings to this role is so tangible
it is so moving her performance is
phenomenal and deb as a character is
really strong she's really flawed she's
really fleshed out which is so nice to
see in a female role especially and she
totally makes her own rules she's
successful she's hilarious she's there's
no like playing politics in the
workplace she does what she does she's
so unapologetic and my favorite thing
about deb is that she never makes
herself smaller to accommodate anybody
around her which is just one of my
favorite favorite traits in a human
being or character and also despite all
the trauma that she's experienced before
the show her mother passing away as a
teenager her dad being totally
preoccupied totally emotionally
unavailable to her which she talks about
a lot and then also during the show she
just they're just like here's the short
stick here you go down here you go down
here you go to in spite of all that she
has this huge heart that is just so full
of this love for her brother that is so
pure and it's really it's a moving
character to see somebody go through all
that and still be good like truly truly
good and she really is even though
obviously it's dexter and we can't pick
dexter and it's called dexter she really
is the hero of the show and she really
is a step further the tragic hero of
this show and she is dexter's most
heartbreaking victim for sure
yeah and and and we meet her so early on
in in the show and we just developed
this attachment to her right away so
it's a great i mean you can't pick
dexter might as well take dab uh kim
potts you have another take for the best
character not named dexter morgan
um i also love dev very much um but i i
think this character i'm picking on hell
as he was called by legueta which is one
of my favorite things about the show it
just made me laugh every time that she
called him and on hell
we needed him i think he was that kind
of good guy
um even keeled i mean this is a show
again about a serial killer who's
killing serial killers and we've got deb
who we love but she definitely has a lot
of issues of her own to deal with
and i there's also the fact that um
well angel was also a good cop most the
time he was a good guy for for
throughout most of the show and a good
cop and we saw him be a good cop and i
think both of those things were
important the good guy because again
there was so much craziness around us um
on the show it was nice to have that
kind of just even keeled good guy around
all the time and he was you know a good
friend to everyone that he worked with
um he was annoyed by uh mizuka and and
his creepiness around about women um but
that was appropriate he should have been
annoyed by that although
mizuka i i think you could also argue
was a great character a creepy one but a
fun one um
but i think it was also important that
we saw someone who was definitely a good
cop because i think for some people pro
there was probably a question
like should we
should these people have the jobs they
have they have this serial killer right
under their nose but they have no idea
except for of course jokes um but that
didn't end well for him um but so you
know they this is the miami pd but none
of them have any clue what's happening
right underneath their noses so it was
good i think to have this guy who we
established as a good cop so it was just
um you know it wasn't a matter of these
these cops were clueless
uh in general they were good cops
dexter was just really good at what he
did
that's a great point yeah batista is a
good comp and we we acknowledge him as
that so it's not a shortcoming of him as
much as it is dexter is just gracie's
just really good at killing people and
his his sister doesn't get
wise to it initially and it's
we're watching deb and we love their
interactions so much it's almost like we
want to preserve that brother-sister
relationship as long as we can
oh yeah totally and also again this is
the nicest i angel or angel is
absolutely in like my top three favorite
characters i really really adore him and
actually i mean all the performances in
the show are just like stupid good like
the casting is just
like everybody really brings like really
excellent work um my only thing with
angel that makes me choose deb over him
a little bit is because i feel like the
energy that he brings is a little bit
boyish i feel like we see him getting
into bar fights like we see him smoking
weed on the job like we see him cheating
on his wife he gets stuck with you know
he gets caught with sex workers he
marries his boss for a brief amount of
time not great not great thinking so i
feel like we see him kind of have these
kind of like boyish trip ups when we're
like we know that you know better so
it's almost like it's like okay you're
fine
you're like the mary and the pippin for
now but like we got to deal with aragorn
over here which is dev so i feel like
it's just more of like the weight that
deb brings to the overall arc of this
show is just a little bit heavier than
angel's but i do but he is
a really great character i love him and
she's known dexter for so long that we
that we know what sort of relationship
fiber they have developed over years and
years so all right kim your 30 second
rebuttal defending angel slash angel i
again i think that the biggest thing
that he brought to um the show was just
that good example that you know that
these people were good cops that they
weren't just bumbling fools who you know
were were fooled by this guy
that was doing these things right under
their nose it really was just that
dexter was that talented and that he had
learned to use working at the miami pd
to his advantage to get away with things
um
i i
but i
cannot rebut anything about deb one of
the best female characters in a drama
series ever
um jennifer carpenter's performance is
impeccable i mean you really can't say
anything against it um and um if we're
going to talk about new blood in a
little bit i think we can you know we're
seeing that again in the the new series
she's amazing
um continues to be and um it's funny i
interviewed um clyde phillips who's the
he was the
um
showrunner for the first four seasons of
dexter and he's now the showrunner for
new blood and he said that um even just
having jennifer carpenter on set
made michael c hall
embrace dexter more
more you know easily and in a more
relaxed way and it just made him more
relaxed as you know to have her on set
and i think that's
you know it it's another
um
another compliment to her that that as
you said they know each other so well
and so long as characters and she just
i don't know that the show is possible
without deb yeah yeah she she reminded
me grace i'll let y'all get to your
final statements in a sec but but the
character of deb when we meet her she
reminded me of judy hopps from zootopia
the uh
just like just like ready to get out
there and it doesn't matter if you're if
you're just giving people parking
tickets or you're solving real quick
like she's just she's in it for whatever
you get to do here and always has these
great career aspirations so uh the final
argument here in this round goes to
grace first grace once again supporting
judy hopps i mean deborah morgan
i mean i love a girl with the potty
mouth and look i feel like if dexter was
a skeleton deb is truly the spine angel
might be a hand maybe the right hand but
she's still the spine
yeah and keeping with the zootopia i'm
not going to say that the the batista
would be the sloth that's working at the
dmv i think there's some other
characters that might more fit that line
for dexter so uh kim i'm going to give
you the final argument here in round
number three as far as the favorite
character
let's stop for your guy batista one more
time
um i'm gonna
angel was also very important again for
us to believe that these people were
were talented cops who you know weren't
just being fooled by someone who was
working with them and getting around
them um
and he he absolutely as grace said he
made some missteps too um
but you know he was human and we needed
that kind of
again straight laced for the most part
um
a straightforward even keeled kind of
guy who who got along with almost
everyone for the most part we needed
that kind of character um
in this show of
people with a lot of issues
yeah and it was
i think it really helped us as the
audience watching him react to to dexter
because there's moments in the show
where dexter is looking at at a dead
body or parts of a dead body and he's
just got that weird smile on his face
like man this is cool and then batista
is usually the one looking back at him
like like what are you
but he never suspects that it's dexter
but we never pinned that on batista just
because he is a good cop and we needed
that in the show so much because there's
at least one other person at the
precinct that doubts dexter and thinks
he's up to something but batista we
always just he grounds the show so well
for us yeah but like like really both of
y'all said deb is just so important to
have because that humanizes dexter so
while batista is there to make us feel
like dexter is just that good in that
secret of a serial killer
deborah makes us feel like this her
brother can actually become a human
being at some point it can actually show
some emotion can actually be a good
brother can be a good human being at at
points during the show and so the way
that both their storylines unfold
there's a lot of action that they both
have to deal with but i am going to give
the w in this round to deborah morgan
she's just too important to the show and
and i loved hearing that that kim you
almost supported grace's argument there
which again we're all just having fun
here but i loved hearing that about new
blood that just having her on set made
michael see hall more like dexter i know
it made me
i felt like i wanted to be on the set
too that just
and that and you know that they had that
relationship was because we also know
they were actually married off
off-camera uh during the show which was
weird to find out as a fan
uh at the time
and um
and then of course there was the
storyline where deb developed feelings
for dexter so it's there's a lot to this
show on screen and off screen um but
jennifer carpenter is again just so
amazing
and we know obviously michael c hall is
and has been in everything he's done um
i just love as a fan of the show to know
that they still have that chemistry
together and that you know in real life
that is chemistry that they have
together
well folks as we were about to kick off
round number four wouldn't you know it
tech snafus happened it's almost like
dexter was in our system manipulating
something and unfortunately one of our
competitor kim potts's computer had some
sort of issue that we just were not able
to resolve after multiple attempts and
so after talking it over with the powers
that be here rotten tomatoes we figured
what better way to continue to celebrate
dexter than by keeping grace hancock
here and grace first of all
congratulations by proxy you are
declared the winner of today's binge
battle it's gotta feel great
you know i just i i knew this day would
come and i just i knew i was gonna win
something and i'm sad that it had to
happen like this but i'm gonna take the
win regardless so thank you well you did
have the lead uh when we were entering
round number four two to one but i still
want to talk about some of these
questions with you just because it's fun
to revisit a show that now has literally
new blood that's attracting a lot of new
fans and getting more people to binge
and go back and watch these classic
seasons of dexter and maybe some not so
classic seasons and so that was kind of
the topic of
four is that we have all these shocking
moments that we've had throughout the
seasons of dexter some for better and
some for worse but if we were to play
that round out what would have been your
most shocking moment in the history of
dexter
oh yeah for sure and i feel really
strongly about this for me it hands down
has to be deb killing
that was absolutely i didn't know that
that was going to happen literally until
like the moment that it happened when
she did it because you know throughout
this whole show is really she's the
she's the moral compass she's really the
living harry and then as we see in new
blood she's kind of you know replaces
harry in a way to dexter and this is her
sacrificing all of her values her
identity it steals her fate in a lot of
ways because this incident directly
leads to her death like directly leads
to her you know horrible demise and i
think that this is also a huge shift
because we always knew that this day
would come we always knew it was never a
question of deb finding out who dexter
was but nobody ever saw her not only
accepting dexter after a little bit of a
rocky period but then additionally
protecting dexter by taking out somebody
so it's like we see a lot of other times
where dexter is taking out a bad guy and
dexter is taking out a bad guy nobody
ever saw a good guy taking out a good
guy like i certainly did not and it's a
really i mean that scene lands like that
scene lands painfully like her like
cradling maria's body is like i mean i
get like misty i mean her performance is
amazing uh but it's i did not see that
coming it's my job
yeah of the whole interaction because
laguerreza just gives debbie such a hard
time right from the outset um and it
what did you make of that was that tough
love for you and and just try making a
rookie prove themselves or did you look
at their initial relationship dynamic as
she just is never going to be won over
by this newbie right i i did kind of see
it i did see warmth there there
definitely was a lot of tough love but i
think also like dexter was kind of ahead
of its time having a woman of color
being the lieutenant of this homicide in
a very male dominated field which i
thought was really awesome and then
later being replaced by deb uh i think
that there was a lot of tough love but i
think there was you know it was almost
maria being like hey this is not gonna
be easy like i'm not gonna make it
easier for you because nobody else is
either so you either gotta hit the
ground running and kind of put on your
big girl panties because this is not
going to be easy and it certainly was
not for either of them
and so something else that wasn't easy
at least for fans to just be like
how do i not talk about this with
everyone i've ever met was the climax
and i guess the big reveal of season one
and this was going to be kim's argument
was talking about who the ice truck
killer actually is lo and behold
dexter's brother just curious how did
that land for you
i well what one thing i was going to say
to kim it's a great i love i love that
that reveal was great i loved it i did
almost in a way see it coming a couple
episodes before i don't know that it was
as shocking as deb's uh killing of
laguerra so that was the only reason why
i was kind of like because it was all
kind of like yeah that makes sense like
i feel i feel pretty good about that but
also i just felt like even though again
and i love it and season one other than
season four is hands down my my very
favorite season uh but it's i just feel
like dead the thing with had higher
stakes because it's like we knew brian
was bad we expect we know and trust
dexter to take out the trash like
literally and figuratively so it's like
i was like oh yeah that's a cool twist
but we knew that at the end of the
season dexter's gonna handle it like we
can trust dexter to make it all happen
but like with deb it was so like
convoluted and so complicated it's like
well now what do we do because she's a
good guy oh god and then she you know
goes off the deep end and stuff like
that so but i do i love him being the
brother and like having that backstory
with like laura moser and all that i
like that tying a lot
just from my interactions with you in
real life as friends i i know you're a
big true crime fan do do all your many
hours of research help inform you when
you're watching a show like dexter
because i am such a babe in the woods
i'm a dummy when it comes to watching
shows where you're guessing who did what
like who's the real killer all that
stuff i did not see the ice truck thing
coming at all are you just trained at
this point to see these things coming
because you're such a fan of this genre
oh i think so for sure like almost to
what i might you know like an unhealthy
level maybe like full weird uh like i
will figure out dateline before the
first commercial break like i've got it
like i know what's happening and that
does come up a lot in texture like i
swear i like know things i've heard
detectives say and investigators say and
i'm definitely like oh yeah it's the
thing and then ken's you know over there
like what and lo and behold i'm correct
so i think it definitely does so maybe
that's why i i blame keith morrison for
ruining that reveal for me it's his
fault yeah well if you and i are ever
teamed up to investigate something
you're taking the lead because i'm
watching dateline and literally after
the last commercial i'm like well i know
he buried the bodies there but i mean
there could be a twist like let's see
um
well the twist in this show is that
congrats grace you win round four and
thus the match i know it's an exciting
moment for you it was on see i didn't
even see that coming that's how bad i am
at this yeah this this feels right this
feels good this is heavy i don't take
this lightly thank you
we did have a question that we were
gonna have just in case of a tiebreaker
and that was gonna be the worst moment
in the show so dexter is famous for for
being great in a groundbreaking show in
many ways but there are a lot of fans
that left somewhat cold by a lot of the
events particularly in the later seasons
in dexter so what was the worst moment
in the show for you as a fan you know i
think that dexter has a couple low
moments um i think it's hard not to for
eight seasons which is pretty
extraordinary run um but there's a lot
of highs it definitely there's more
highs but for me absolutely and i know
we're gonna we might touch on the series
finale which is you know just rough but
for me the absolute the one that i hate
the most only because at least the end
of the show was like a quick band-aid
what we had to suffer through for 12
episodes in season five was
lumen comes in and dexter comes in she's
had this horrible trauma he's had this
horrible loss and they're sort of like
healing each other and falling in love
but in this kind of weird dark way and
he's never connected with like a
romantic partner in a healthy way that's
also a serial killer there's a lot of
serial killing in miami apparently and
it's like you see this like build in
this building this build and then
literally at the end she's like so that
was great i'm gonna go and i was
literally like
it was literally brand taking the throne
all over again if i could take season
five out of dexter cannon i would and
quite frankly season six too but i was
so upset because you really it was like
earned it was like there was a lot of i
was like this is okay like this is and
then it was absolutely for nothing i
felt totally like the rug got ripped out
from underneath me and i'm still mad
about it this assumption i i should tell
the boss uh christian ruble cobb our
beloved engineer and producer that maybe
put a pin in in something like that
because we could have that binge battle
at some point what was the more
disappointing series finale game of
thrones or dexter were you a pretty
i guess upset might be too strong of a
word but your feelings on the entire
season finale that was dexter
um
pretty rough for me this is like i know
a lot of people are like nose game of
thrones and a lot of people were like no
screw lost they totally lost me at the
end like like i actually you know game
of thrones i had issues with but i
enjoyed like lost i loved this was
absolutely terrible this is my
like this is i hate this finale so much
and it was just very it was so jarring
and off color and like felt kind of
strangely out of left field like it
didn't feel earned it was very kind of
dark and heavy which of course it was
going to be dark and heavy but it just i
i did not like it i still don't like it
i was doing a re-watch recently and i
was dreading getting to that episode
it's and it still hurts just as much
you know you have all these serious
finales that maybe didn't stick the
landing you mentioned lost and dexter
and game of thrones somewhere jerry
seinfeld is just like see mine wasn't
that bad
right
i know i've heard i haven't seen this is
terrible i've never seen sci i've seen
like here and there but i didn't like
officially watch seinfeld but i've heard
a lot i've heard i've heard some things
oh boy finally
i have a tv leg up on grace hancock
after all these years well uh you are a
winner once again and so i guess we'll
try to end it on a positive note not
talking about the worst series finale
possibly of all time but dexter new
blood as of the recording of this i
believe we're only one episode deep and
they're releasing them weekly so we're
all kind of living week to week how are
you feeling so far about the potential
of this new sort of reboot
yeah it's like a sort of reboot like
sort of part two kind of thing i mean
i'm really excited when i saw that the
episode has dropped like i literally
said to my partner ken that you know i
was like no this is like my prequels
like this is like this is happening
right now at 12 30 at night so i was
really excited i was maybe ever so
slightly lukewarm with the delivery i
felt like it was it didn't hit as hard
as i wanted to i felt like obviously i
think we were all thinking that the
boots were going to be harrison i think
we were all kind of like on the same
page with that but i just felt it was
very uh it just wasn't it was super it
felt kind of flat like he was just like
dad it's me and he was like well i gotta
go that's not me and then that was kind
of the i was like
like i wanted it to be more of a thing i
wanted more emotional payoff and i think
we know
kind of where this is going so i'm
totally hooked i'm gonna be there like
absolutely every week but i was a little
bit nervous with that episode i'm hoping
that it like picks up and there's more
of like a
thing to it but seeing deb like blew my
mind i was like
like it's so i loved that that was maybe
my favorite part is how they did that
yeah and that was something that it was
really interesting hearing kim talk
about earlier in our show today where
just having her around on set the the
makers of the show were like oh well i
mean you really just see michael c hall
just light up as as dexter just being
around that sort of energy and so it
really is nice that it's one big happy
family on that show now a lot of them
may not make it through to the end but
it's still
it's a nice celebration of something and
you're just gonna is it gonna be torture
for you waiting waiting a week for each
new episode are you kidding me i'm like
a redheaded rage monster like if i don't
have it five hours ago i'm already mad
so i'm like it's gonna be torture
because it'll be airing until january of
next year
she is a sweetheart don't let her fool
you and as as is kim pots and so i'm
bummed that either kim had some sort of
a thing in her computer that was a
glitch or grace stole her modem because
that's how bad grace wanted to win but
either way you're the binge battle
winner well thank you thank you i and
kim was great i really enjoyed her her
perspectives on things it was fun it's
not like i like talking about tv like
this like this is this is grace nerd
stuff and i'm happy this was a lot of
fun and if you want to go a little bit
further back in the history of tv uh kim
potts has a great book that you can
check out from grand central publishing
about the brady bunch called the way we
all became the brady bunch and for more
on her you can check out
kimberlypots.com
grace where can everybody find you and
all the cool things you're working on i
know you always have a million projects
that you're juggling what's the latest
and where can all the folks follow it
yeah for sure you can follow me online
everywhere on socials at mrs gray's face
everywhere i have a horror film pretty
boy coming out earlier in the year next
year and then i have a film coming out
on disney plus which will now be more
expensive i'm very sorry but i have a
film coming out on that probably later
of next year as well
i was just on truth be told on apple tv
plus you'll see me on shows here and
there so come and find me i'm a lot of
fun
working too hard oh but i see these
streaming recommendations you have
because we also get streaming
recommendations to say now you said
you've never seen seinfeld yet i'm
looking at a streaming recommendation of
yours that seems like maybe you should
have seen seinfeld already
i know i know well i it's kirby
enthusiasm which also kind of feels like
sort of a cop-out recommendation because
i feel like everybody kind of like knows
about that show but maybe not uh but no
but it but i do i have people who will
explain the references to me and curb
your enthusiasm but i love that show
it's very funny it's really really i
like that humor like very dry humor it's
good and again doing it after you've
done a long dexter re-watch of 8 000
hours of murder it's like probably a
good like balancing like to balance out
that content
i don't hate a crossover style show
where larry david is a serial killer
because i could very easily see him just
be so annoyed with the everyday quirks
that people have and he just ends up
bearing the bodies i mean are you
telling me right now that his buddy jeff
would not help him bury whatever he had
to bury in the desert 100 him leon i see
the whole team like being like all right
fine we gotta bury this like all right
woodwatch
and i love that you're also a fan of
what we do in the shadows and uh the
programming alert we also the the
podcast that i'm lucky enough to host
alongside the great jacqueline coley
rotten tomatoes is wrong we just had
harvey guillen who of course plays
guillermo the familiar on that show uh
we were talking about the movie selena
and he is was such a delight to talk to
and so it's what we do in the shadows
meeting selena meeting dexter this binge
battle there's just a whole lot of fun
stuff happening all over here wherever
you enjoy your rotten tomatoes content
once again grace hancock thank you so
much for joining binge battle and i look
forward to seeing both you and kim again
we'll find another show for you all to
have your rematch yeah yeah no thank you
so much for having me this was awesome
this was so much fun the fates aligned
and that's the way it goes here at a
binge battle on behalf of christian
rubicon with the boss man i am merely
mark ellis for everybody here at rotten
tomatoes our incredible competitors kim
potts and grace hancock thanks so much
for tuning in to this episode and we'll
see you soon on a new episode of binge
battle
bring it on